The Eagle has landed!
So hieß vor fast 50 Jahren!
2019 jährt sich die Mondlandung der Apollo
11 1969 zum 50.
Mal.
Heute gibt es eine weitere Pioniertat zu verkünden:
Zum ersten Mal ist eine Mondsonde auf der
Rückseite des Mondes gelandet.
Und es ist eine chinesische Sonde.
Damit haben die Chinesen einen Meilenstein
erreicht.
Denn auf der Rückseite des Mondes zu landen
ist nicht gerade einfach, weswegen es bisher
auch noch niemand gemacht hat.
Clixoom Science & Fiction.
Hier gibt es täglich spannende Wissenschaftsvideos.
Abonniert den Kanal, nur dann verpasst ihr
nichts.
Herzlich willkommen.
Bisher haben es alle Weltraumnationen gescheut
auf der Rückseite zu landen, weil das mit
deutlich erhöhtem Aufwand verbunden ist.
Denn nicht nur der Lander muss zum Mond geschickt
werden, sondern auch ein Mondsatellit als
Relaisstation, um die Signale an die Erde
zu senden.
Denn ein solcher Lander kann von der Rückseite
nicht direkt senden, weil der Mond ja dazwischen
ist.
Das geht nur über einen Satelliten, der von
der Erde aus gesehen werden kann und vom Lander,
quasi über Eck wird dann gesendet.
Und das bedeutet auch, dass die Landung nicht
direkt kontrolliert werden kann.
Alles geht nur über den Satelliten.
Deshalb musste dieser Satellit extra für
die Mission im Mai in den Mondorbit gebracht
werden.
Und noch etwas ist schwieriger auf der Rückseite
des Mondes.
Er ist nicht so eben, wie die Vorderseite.
Eine Landung ist auch deswegen schwieriger.
Jetzt ist es also gelungen um 3:36 Mitteleuropäischer
Zeit.
Jetzt wird ein Roboterfahrzeug den Lander
verlassen und die Umgebung untersuchen.
Neben diversen Messgeräten ist auch eine
Panoramakamera an Bord.
Zusätzlich ist auch ein kleines Gewächshaus
mit auf dem Mond und es wird getestet, wie
Pflanzen bei der niedrigen Gravitation des
Mondes wachsen.
Und es werden niedrigfrequente Radiofrequenzen
gemassen.
Auf der Rückseite des Mondes gibt es kaum
Störungen durch Strahlung von der Erde, so
dass man hier erhofft deutlich ungestörter
ins All zu horchen.
Zudem ist ein Strahlenmessgerät der Kieler
Christian-Albrechts-Universität mit dabei,
das die Strahlung und den Wassergehalt des
Bodens messen wird.
Und im kommenden Jahr wird es für die Chinesen
weitergehen.
Mit Chang’e 5 wollen sie Mondgestein einsammeln
und zur Erde zurückbringen und 2030 soll
ein Chinese zum ersten Mal seinen Fuß auf
den Mond setzen.
Und auch Flüge zum Mars sind geplant.
Der Wettlauf ins All ist also wieder in vollem
Gange.
Und wir können gespannt sein, wer als erstes
dem Fuß auf den Mars setzen wird.
Wenn es dazu neues gibt erfahrt ihr es natürlich
bei Clixoom, auch auf dem englischen Kanal,
wo es heute für euch eine Videopremiere gibt.
LED lights damage Eyes Da erfahrt ihr, warum
LED-Lampen für unsere Augen gefährlich sind.
Ich freue mich auf euch auch auf dem englischen
Kanal.
See you soon, stay Tuned.